If you were transformed into
a full flesh and skin cyborg by aliens,
what would you do?
You'll be forced to battle
another killer cyborg
and watch millions of innocent people die.
I'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do
and how to beat the evil cyborg
in a new yoshiki.
This old man has no idea
he will soon be transformed into a living,
breathing cyborg.
By nightfall, Ichiro
here is wasting his humdrum life away,
letting his old man days
pass him by with a wife and two kids.
Although he might as well be invisible
as no one appreciates him today,
on the most average of days,
his life is changed forever, as he is
suddenly told that he has stomach cancer
and has only three months left to live.
His meaningless life
will now soon come to an end.
Terrified and saddened,
he debates telling his family.
But from the looks of things,
no one gives two shits.
He decides to take a walk in the park
to clear his head.
And that's when he sees
the most terrifying thing an alien ship
coming at him at light speed.
Within half a second, his entire body
is crushed by this gigantic ship.
As these aliens decide to fix him
by putting it back together
with a robot suit before they fly away,
and that's when Ichiro wakes up.
But this is only the beginning for him.
And the entire city of Japan
is about to feel the wrath of a cybernetic
robot very soon. OK, if I was Ichiro,
I wouldn't panic just yet.
Reports of publicized alien encounters
go way back to 1961
and sightings of flying saucers
date back to the 1940s.
But I'd first consider the possibility
that we just hallucinated
the shit out of our situation,
which could have resulted
due to us passing out and going into deep
sleep or REM sleep.
REM or rapid eye movement
is the deepest phase of our sleep cycle
where we could have experienced
the common phenomenon known as awareness
during sleep paralysis as this is known,
to cause deep hallucinations
when the person wakes up
before the paralysis disappears.
This can also cause
false memory formations.
And if I'm an old guy who's tired of life
like him and has just been told
that I have cancer
and only a few months left to live,
maybe my brain might short circuit
and just start to hallucinate
crap on the spot,
because if an entire ship
really just crashed into us
and we're still alive to think about it,
that either means it didn't happen
since we're not dead
or it did happen and we died
and came back to life by alien Supertech.
So realistically,
there's no need to panic yet.
Ichiro then goes about his day,
but something is off and he realizes
that he's super thirsty, craving water
like he's never craved it before.
His back pain is gone.
He doesn't need glasses, and every little
old man problem of his is suddenly gone.
Even the doctors can figure out
how his cancer disappeared, as Ichiro
has never felt better.
He feels almost inhuman, but he can tell
that something is seriously wrong.
At home, he then goes to pet his dog,
and that's when he sees it.
His arms start steaming up
and they turn into a huge alien ray gun
right before his very eyes.
Lights and lasers under human flesh
and skin is what remains as Ichiro opens
up, even more revealing to us
an entire cybernetic human
machine inside Ichiro himself.
This is too much crazy
for Ichiro to handle.
And his family is hearing the racket,
meaning he needs to get out of there now.
He escapes the house
and heads out to the back
to the very place
where it all started, the park.
And that's when he remembers
that someone else
was at that park with him, a kid,
which means Ichiro has to find him.
ASAP, as that kid may remember
what happened that night.
And that's when it hits him
the loudest noises
he's ever heard as all of a sudden
his hearing, like a new Spidey sense
alerts him to some kids
beating up a hobo nearby.
And Ichiro can't seem to turn away,
but he doesn't know
how to switch to his Reagan,
which means he's in trouble as these kids
look mean as hell and have baseball bats.
But unfortunately,
like Ganta in Deadman, Wonderland
being a hero proves to be a stupid goal.
And he struggles to show the kids
who's boss until he passes out,
and then his body takes over in
self-defense mode and scares the kids off.
OK, well, I do admire Ichiro hero complex.
We don't even know if we're still trippin
or if we indeed have super robot powers.
So I would avoid helping Mr.
Hobo Guy until we figure out
what exactly is going on.
In fact, I would have screwed
staying at the family
home, rented some cheap motel
in an unfamiliar area, paid cash,
and would have spent the night
messing around, trying to figure out just
what the hell is going on with my body.
But fine, let's be like Ichiro for a sec.
Be a good man. Well, for starters,
attacking these punks head on was stupid.
There was clearly a lot of bushes
and shrubbery around them,
which means we could have used that
to sneak up from behind
to close the distance
and being there were multiple assailants.
I could have told you
that engaging with them to begin
with was stupid,
as there was no way we could have won
Ichiro should have called the cops first,
and then he could have tried attacking
from the rear during the fireworks.
It's clear that some of their bats
were on the floor,
which would have made swiping one easy.
However, you'd only have gotten
a few shots in before being outnumbered.
This is why you should never
try to be a hero.
Kids stay in school the next day.
The other kid who died with Ichiro
during the alien crash
Shishigami meets up with his old school
friend, Ando, to show him something
just as special as Ichiro's powers.
Turns out that he's a robot, too,
and one who's way more deadly than Ichiro
already mastering his powers
and showing Ando just.
Exactly what they soon to be robot
killer is capable of.
It's horrifying.
He shows that he can fire a make-believe
finger gun that can actually kill people
with no bullets or gun needed
except his hands.
We see that it is capable
of so much more than we realize.
He is able to control electronics
from controlling TV channels to even cars,
causing traffic accidents with wild hand
gestures like a composer of death itself.
It's terrifying,
but Ando know something is not right.
And asks Shishigami
if maybe he could use his powers
for good saving people
and become a superhero instead.
But Shishigami thinks it's too much work
and tells Ando that if he wants,
he can kill his school
bullies come tomorrow.
Ando thinks he's crazy and shrugs
it off, not realizing
that this is only the beginning
and that Shishigami
is about to get a taste of bloodlust
that no one will be able
to stop after tonight.
Shishigami, then on the way home, stops
by a classmate's house as he hears
some family noises from inside.
Then, like a soldier
without a soul on the battlefield,
Shishigami goes inside the house and kills
every single human inside.
Mother, father and child.
Until the daughter, a classmate
of Shishigami, comes home just in time.
She knows what this girl doesn't, that he
is now a God and willing to kill anybody.
We don't have time to screw around.
This girl could have had a chance
if she acted logically.
But of course, under the circumstances,
she didn't have much
of a chance to begin with.
Our mom is dead on the floor
and there's fresh blood on the walls,
but we ain't no forensic experts.
So she could have been there for hours.
However, there was food
and a kettle on the gas stove
and there was steam
coming from that pot of soup.
But even if there wasn't,
we could have quickly felt up the kettle
to see if it was still warm,
as this would have meant
that her death happened
within the last 30 minutes or so.
And if Shishigami
was blocking the entrance,
then we could have escaped
through another exit point.
I do want to note that in the kitchen
there are curtains on the far
side of the dining table,
which means it's safe
to assume that that was a patio window
from which we could have escaped from
since we were on the ground floor anyways.
Gosh darn it. Why are teenagers so stupid?
The piercing screams of Shishigami
horrified classmate punctures
Ichiro supersonic hearing
as he realizes that someone is in trouble.
But too bad for him as he's
stuck in traffic.
He does his best to get there
quicker than a hot pizza.
But Japan's mini back
alley streets proved too much for him.
And he shows up late and that's
when he sees the most horrifying thing
anyone has ever seen.
A dead mother shot through the chest
with blood dripping on the wall and a girl
barely older than her own daughter
laying dead on the floor.
Then Shishigami catches him
right there and not batting an eye, shoots
Ichiro dead before leaving the house.
But Ichiro is built of tougher stuff
than my self-image.
And he rises back up to take on Shishi.
But it's too late.
Shishigami flies off
without a care in the world.
Ichiro then realizes that the most
powerful superhuman in the world
other than him is a villain.
And he's right here in Japan.
These deaths are only the beginning,
and millions and millions more will die
very soon. Whoa.
Okay, hold on. We need to press the pause
button on this one.
Ichiro has balls of steel for sure, but
frankly rushed in unprepared as all hell.
The screams clearly stopped way
before he got there.
So I would have taken this opportunity
to slow everything down
and perhaps switch over to do some recon
on this potential bad guy.
We still don't know how our powers work,
so we still need to rely mainly
on our wits. For now, it's cold hearted.
But since the screams clearly stopped,
we should assume that anybody worth
saving is already dead.
We could have waited at a distance
in our car for the murderer to come out,
and then this would have had,
at the very least, given us some options
as to how to take him on, either
trailing him to his house or another area
where he would have been less
on edge and alert.
The next night, Ichiro is heading home
when he comes across Agang,
bothering a poor old dude.
So he steps up to show
these punks who's boss.
But this time fare's off
worse than last night,
and he can't even get a punch through
until he does, knocking this gang member
720 degrees and he flips over
like a Japanese flapjack.
Ichiro now means business,
and these punks don't stand a chance.
Ichiro saves the day,
but the night's not over yet.
As he hears more squeals and screams
using his robot senses, he triangulates
the location of the screams
and needs to fly there. Only one problem.
He doesn't know how.
So Ichiro then find some open
space strips off exotically as the world
and some parents
take a sneak peek at his strangeness.
But no matter as he's running out of time,
so with some fiddling
and some strange singing,
he takes out his rockets
and blasts off Ichiro, struggles to fly
and almost hits a building
as he haphazardly plops right down
in front of a massive building on fire.
But time is running out and this family's
scared. Please are getting fainter.
Ichiro dashes in and manages
to save this family like the old man study
is what he runs away
before the ambulances arrives.
This guy is insane.
But this time we don't
have time to back down
and we got to take on multiple bad guys.
So we need to focus and think.
We still don't know how what
we have works, but
we definitely have something inside us,
which is why we need to remember
every strange single detail
since the alien crash
that we can think of that stands out.
And one thing that comes to mind
was our incredible thirst for water,
like on that first day, if. I was Ichiro.
This sign would have been enough
to make me think
that staying hydrated
has something to do with our powers,
and so I would have topped up
on some water before
going down that alley full of gangsters.
Then I would have tried to replicate
how my arm transformed into a ray gun
earlier with the dog,
which would have involved
some type of haptic feedback
or some interaction with something
towards my arm, like either a dog lick
or hitting my own arm or anything to
perhaps set it off
and have it transform into a weapon.
Hell, I would have tried pouring water on
my arm to see if that would have worked.
And for good measure,
the location that the gang members took,
that man is surrounded
by apartment windows.
I would have screamed fire
or help as I walk down the alley,
which would have likely garnered attention
for people inside those buildings
to take a look outside.
This could have acted as a deterrent
and preventing the gang members
from attacking us,
as there would have been more
than enough witnesses
inside all of those buildings.
It's no guarantee that we still wouldn't
have gotten our asses kicked,
but it's definitely worth a shot.
Running away before the fire department
and police arrived was actually incredibly
smart as the last thing we want
is more public attention
on our new weaponized selves.
I am worried, though,
that we may end up being abducted
by some kind of secret government agency
to be experimented on. Crazy thought,
I know, but think about it.
And you know, I'm half right later
at school, Ando, is in for a beating
as his favorite school bullies
show up to give him some shit.
But Shishigami isn't having any of it.
As he grabs this school, bullies rest
and slowly crushes it.
Making this punk whip harder than me
at the ending of King's game, Ando,
then makes him release his wrist.
And this angers the rest of the Schachte
bullies who demand that Ando.
And Shishigami meet them at the roof
at the end of school.
But that was their biggest mistake.
After school ends,
judgment day arrives and Ando
when Shishigami show up to the roof.
But the bullies are nowhere to be found.
Shishigami is calmness to the situation
makes Ando think something is eerily wrong
and he has a very bad
feeling for what's to come as Shishigami
menacingly hands him a pair of binoculars.
Then he starts pointing his finger
gun and begins rattling gun noises.
He begins firing fake gunshots
into the distance like a mad man.
But that's when Ando sees that
the most horrifying thing
his teenage life has ever seen.
In the distance, bodies
of dead teenagers, his school bullies,
their corpses lying there with faint
screams surrounding the horror by teenage
girls who just witnessed the massacre.
It's a bloodbath
and Shishigami doesn't even blink.
It's then when we find out
what Shishigami true powers
are being able to see a kilometer away,
being able to shoot someone
from 10 kilometers away,
being able to not just tap into all the
electronics in Japan, but the world.
Shishigami here is the most advanced
robot in the history of the world,
and he's not happy with Japan.
OK, this is insane.
But let's think about this for a sec.
There's no way we can overpower
or stop our friend
Shishigami from doing whatever he wants.
And likely no government or country
even can stop him without a ton of deaths.
But we do have one thing in our favor.
And hear me out,
Shishigami is our best friend,
which means if we play our cards right,
we could literally do whatever we wanted
on earth and no one could stop us.
Like the childhood
best friend of a major celebrity,
we could have all the perks of being
within the radius of someone as powerful
and as influential as she me.
If I was Arndale, I'd
pick my tongue up off the floor
and sack up and be content with the fact
that my best friend is a major psychopath
and invincible killer robot.
This way, I could take advantage of him
by getting whatever I want in life
without having to work for it
as long as I keep him happy.
This shouldn't cost me too much. Crazy,
I know, but I'm damn smart.
Let's be honest.
On the way home, Ando, begs Shishigami
to change his ways. But he refuses.
So Ando ends the friendship,
and they part ways.
On the other side of town,
we see another power
that these two cyborgs are capable of,
but a power of which Shishigami
does not use the ability
to heal people and animals from near death
as we see Ichiro
healing a cat on the brink of death.
This power is his most
treasured possession
and one that will save many lives shortly.
Time is running out for the city of Japan
as we meet this young couple in love,
as they go about their day
until a van pulls over and kidnaps
the woman, bringing her to this
tall dude's apartment.
As we find out, he's
yakuza and he's willing to kill anyone
to have this girl seven feet tall.
He stands over her
and is about to have his way
until this girl quickly grabs his menacing
sword to defend herself, cutting him
and his ego just enough to quickly
escape the prison hotel room in time
running home, she comes face to face
with a tall dude and his minions again,
just as Ichiro shows up to save the day.
But he is no match for tall dudes firearm.
After a couple of shots to the face,
he passes out from the
looks of the outside of this apartment.
I wouldn't be surprised
if the corridors within
those apartments were narrow as all hell,
which we could have used to our advantage
rather than face the gangsters
and that couples' room.
We could have waited
till they exited the apartment,
taking on one gangster at a time
as they passed through the doorway,
minimizing our blind spots
by fighting within a confined space.
Now it's clear that we can take a ton of
abuse from baseball bats and other things.
Well, that still doesn't mean
that Adro shouldn't
try to at least protect
his face as tall dude
was blasting him in the head with his gun.
If he wanted to play it super safe,
we could have waited till the gangsters
exited the apartment and surprized tall
dude first, rather than attacking any of.
His henchmen sense from his stature
alone, it's clear that he's the toughest,
and when handling a group,
you want to take out their leader
first, demoralizing the whole group
after waking up, he saves this guy's life,
bringing him back
the good old fashioned way,
and he then tracks down
where all the yakuza are.
Turns out there's a big meeting
and all the mob bosses have been invited.
This means that Ichiro has to find out
where the kidnaped girl is being held,
which means he's got to get
the information out of tall dude himself.
And just like the bumbling, lovable idiot
that he is, he fudges
it all up by showing up at the front door
of the Yakuza mansion.
No sneakiness needed.
And this pisses off the yakuza,
who take out even more of their firearms
to show Ichiro, who's boss, firing
countless rounds at him and into him,
making him pass out from all the shock.
But like at the playground before,
his cybernetic body goes into self-defense
mode and unleashes a mysterious ray beam
that blinds and injures
all the yakuza men,
providing them with a fate
worse than death ineptitude.
Despite the non killing approach,
it's a gruesome mess as everyone's
eyes are scorched from Ichiro ray beam.
Blood being spilled everywhere.
Ichiro then wakes up like nothing
ever happened and goes on his merry way.
Tracking down the kidnaped girl
by using tall dudes phone
and to add to all of the horror
Ichiro in the world
find out that a massive meteorite
is headed for Earth
and that the Americans
are trying to stop it. Oh, my gosh.
I guess we don't need to worry
about what happens when we pass out.
Sheesh. Now, we know that
Ichiro has the full capability
of taking on a bunch of thugs head on,
but this was unnecessary
effort for no reason.
It's easy to assume
why Mr. Tall Dude kidnaped that girl.
And the last time Ichiro saw him,
he was with the girl and his thugs.
We could have deduced that
by the kidnaped girl.
Now, being with him at this meeting
that it was likely
he would have headed back to her
after the meeting was finished.
Ichiro could have simply waited
outside in his car
at some distance away
until the meeting was over.
He then could have tailed behind Mr.
Tall Dude and followed him
back to the hotel that she was being held
in, taking him in
a few of his thugs on without needing
to go through the entire yakuza clan.
Like I said, unnecessary
effort for no reason.
Later on, Ando, searches on his computer,
desperately trying to find
more information about Shishigami
and his robot body as he knows
that it is only a matter of time before
Shishigami kills thousands of people.
First, it's the bullies, then random
strangers homes, then the whole of Japan
Ando finds out that there must be someone
else out there other than Shishigami,
who got turned into a cyborg.
And that's when it hits him.
Earlier, Shishigami mentioned
that he has supersonic hearing
or fake screams for his life.
Sure enough, this catches
the attention of Ichiro,
who shows up a few moments later
and then finally meets the famous cyborg,
befriending him and finding out who he is
and what he can do.
Ando makes it clear to Ichiro
that Shishigami has gone crazy
and wants to help Ichiro
stop him before it's too late.
And Ichiro agrees
to work with him,
heading off to train properly
for their upcoming epic battle
that will soon come
at the cost of sacrificing
thousands of Japanese citizens.
OK, we need to be careful here,
because if Ando here was best buds
with my worst enemy a week ago,
then we can't trust that
he'll stick to our side.
And on top of that, we don't know if he's
playing both sides, double crossing
both of us to get what he wants
or if he truly wants to help us out.
And working with someone
so close to Shishigami, while invaluable,
can be dangerous as at the last minute,
Ando, may not have what he truly takes
to help us take Shishigami out, harming us
or our plan to kill him eventually.
And I don't know
if it's ultimately worth it,
but if he truly wants to help us,
then this would make him
the perfect informant, letting us know
the inner workings of Shishigamis
powers, and most importantly,
giving us an insight into his mind.
And this way, we can even help
find out what our powers are based on
what Ando finds out from Shishigami.
Since he's clearly ahead of us,
we need to learn everything
there is to know
about our cybernetic powers.
However, I would work on some ways
to test on those loyalty
first before letting him in on our plan
or working with him at all.
This way, we can be sure that, unlike us,
he won't play both sides
to get what he wants,
screwing us over in the process.
Back at the junkyard, Ando, shows
Ichirojust what he's capable of
based on what he saw from Shishigami.
Making him the perfect informant
and inside man into
Shishigami is craziness itself.
Elsewhere, we see Shishigami and his shady
family upbringing.
His mother barely making ends meet
and his situation with his estranged dad,
who has a second family.
Thanks to these people,
the entire city of Japan
will pay for their mistakes and to add
even more fuel to this fiery situation.
His mom has just been diagnosed
with cancer and claims
to only have a few months left to live.
This breaks Shishigami as he heals her
with this special robot powers and offers
to help him move her out with money.
He got thanks to stocks,
which is, of course, a lie.
And mom, of course, is none
the wiser and agrees to move out soon.
However, their cute reunion is cut short
as Japanese policemen bust down
Shishi gummies door,
thanks to the killings of the teenage
bullies and random murders
around the neighborhood.
Shishigami has caught too much attention
and now the police want blood.
However, this was their biggest mistake
and will single handedly cost
Japan thousands of gruesome deaths.
Shishigami bolts out of the back window
as he runs away from the cops.
How? Over he's cornered by dozens more and
his reign of terror is about to be over.
Just kidding. Shishi got me
proved to be too smart for these cops
and manages to lose them without a trace.
Now, Shishigami is loose
and pissed off. Holy shit.
These cops said they have
permission to fire,
which is no small thing in Japan,
especially if you consider that
Japan has one of the lowest
police killings per country
at a rate of two
people killed by police shootings
per 10 million citizens
compared to somewhere like Brazil,
which has a police
killing of six thousand one hundred
sixty per 10 million citizens.
This means they are not messing around
and don't care about the fact
that we're still in high school,
which means they have no chill,
which means we're in trouble.
There's no way they would
have been able to tie
the murders to us,
at least initially due to the fact
that there was no murder weapon.
However, Shishigami's
footprints, hair and likely handprints
would have had him at the crime scene.
And we don't know who saw us,
if anyone really did see us.
Which means there's no way we can bet
that a proper court trial will go our way.
Shishigami did everything right
by breaking free and escaping the cops,
especially escaping
without being seen and using his powers.
So long as no one sees us
using our powers.
They'll underestimate us
every step of the way,
not realizing that
they're actually underestimating a God.
Shishigami is now in huge trouble as his
pictures have been released to the public,
giving a face to the monster
behind all the murders.
But this is where Japan royally messed up
and will directly cost them thousands
upon thousands of deaths.
Shishigami luckily
meets a girl from his class, messy
hair girl who has a little crush on him
and gives him shelter
at her Gramma's place while he waits
for all of this to blow over.
But this won't blow over. In fact, it's
just the beginning.
The world quickly
finds out who this killer is.
And all the questions and anger
are aimed at Shishigami mother.
And this causes Shishigami to lose it
the next day as crowds
gather at Shishigami father's place.
Shishigami himself shows up
and he just doesn't give a shit anymore.
And he blasts every single reporter away
with his finger guns, leaving behind
only the dead to watch in horror.
This is horrifying.
We've got a teenager
with the powers of a God,
and he's angry at the whole of Japan.
This is why we need to act quick,
unlike the physics
resistance and puncturing capabilities
of a regular bullet.
There's no way to know what the physics
are behind Shishigami's finger guns,
although I'm willing to bet
that his ordinary finger bullets will obey
the laws of physics to some degree.
If we put something in between us
and him like a wall, for instance,
I would have hid behind the dad initially
before jumping over the small family
gate and hightail it to the backyard of
the house before exiting the other side.
Hiding behind the dad
initially would have given us
a few extra seconds of time
to jump over the wall
because it's his dad.
Maybe there's some
emotional attachment to him.
There is another even more insane method,
which would have been to fall
to the ground and play dead
during all the initial carnage.
As if you notice Shishigami killing
everybody was made
to be more of a statement.
And with the awkwardness of his dad
being there, I think it's safe to say that
cheating on his eyes, wouldn't it
be on any half a breathing corpses?
But on his father's
reaction to the overall situation,
Shishigami is quickly losing it
and the entire world is turning on him,
including all of the hate comments online,
causing him to kill all the commenters
through their screens with his finger gun,
leaving no one alive on the forums
to badmouth his name anymore.
OK, the first warning shot was actually
our greatest reward because it allowed us
to realize that he, in fact,
can get us through the screen.
Although this glasses guy
was too stupid to realize
it's the limited extent of his powers
where through that webcam,
which we could have prevented by either
destroying our computer instantly
or by crouching to
the bottom of the floor,
as it seems from the shots that U.S.
Army needed to at least have some line
of sight to be able to harm glasses.
Guy, too bad for him.
He was a dumb ass.
Later on, she calmly admits to messy hair
girl that he is indeed
the monster that everyone says
he is confessing to all of the deaths,
men, women, children that he has taken.
But turns out Messy hair girl loves psycho
teen boys as she, after a wild ride
by Shishigami, confesses her love to him
and turns out this is all that Shishigami
needed some love as he
then decides to change his bad boy ways,
beginning a business through Twitter,
hoping and healing
sick people from all over the country.
But this is short
lived as one night a Japanese swat bustin
in through Messy girl's apartment,
injuring Messy girl and her grandma.
This is the last straw for Shishigami
and he goes into full
Sith mode, killing all the SWAT members
as he escapes from the apartment.
Japan is now in trouble
as this boy has lost everything
and will make the whole country pay
starting from tomorrow night.
The next day, Ichiro's daughter
catches him and Ando, blowing it out
around town as she even discovers
that her father is a robot.
But at least she has a father,
unlike Shishigami,
who later on in the night decides
to make the entire police force pay
by showing up her right at the police
headquarters, shooting
and killing everyone inside, except one
who is left to spread the horrifying word.
But turns out he's
no match for a sniper rifle.
But that was these cops.
The biggest mistake
as Shishigami passes out from the shot.
His body, like Ichiro, activates
its self-defense mode and destroys
everybody outside the.
Police station, the next day, Shishigami
takes it to the next level
by hacking all of the Jumbotron
TVs in Japan and making the most
horrifying statement of all.
He says he's decided to kill all 125
million people in Japan
and he begins to use his finger
gun and kills everybody and even upgrades
by making a finger machine gun.
Countless and I mean countless dead bodies
lined the streets of Japan, killing men,
women and children.
Everybody, as no one is safe.
Ando realizes that the only people who are
dying are people with their phones out,
meaning Shishigami can only kill people
through their phones and gadgets.
This is not good.
But if we try to be a little bit
more visually aware of what's going on,
there might be a way to survive this.
It's noted that Shishigami can only kill
if he can see who he's shooting at,
whether through a screen or in person
and through a screen.
If that screen is facing someone
without being able to see
who he's actually shooting at all.
The people who died either
died as they were directly by their phone.
But if we notice from this image,
everyone who died
was the furthest away
from the large screens,
whereas not a single person from below
the screens was shot during the shoot out.
This makes me suspect
that if we were close enough
to the large screens out in Tokyo Square,
we may have stood a chance
if we took cover directly below the LED
screens, and from there
we would have remained out of sight
whilst the shoot out carried on.
Provided there were no more TVs
or LCD screens within our line of sight.
By also not using our phones
or by throwing them away,
this could have also
helped our chance of survival.
If none of these options were available,
then I would have thrown my phone
within the fleeing crowds near
me and would have played
dead on the floor near a corpse.
If Shishigami can use his techno
pathy on our phones to find us, then
if we throw our phones away far from us,
then that's one less method for him to use
to find our location and kill us.
Also, if we lay near a corpse
or under a corpse,
this could also confuse Shishigami's
ability to determine our location,
making him unable to get a lock on us
with his telekinesis bullet
and helps Ichiro by spreading the word
saying to the public
that they should get rid of their phones.
And Shishigami finds out that Ando
is somehow stopping the public from dying.
This leads cheating on me
to stop killing for the day, claiming
that today was only a practice run
and that the real killing
will start tomorrow, starting
with one thousand people per day every day
until all one hundred
and twenty five million people are dead.
ando and Ichiro do their best,
but they can't locate Shishigami.
And the next day he takes it up a notch
by disabling all the airplanes in the sky,
causing all of them to fall.
Thousands died within seconds,
crashing into buildings and streets
with explosions following quickly behind.
But this time, Ichiro
is on the case as he manages
to save as many planes as he can.
But that's just when he hears
the worst news of all.
His daughter is trapped in a building
and can't get out.
Ichiro is then about to leave until
Shishigami shows up right in front of him.
OK, first off, after the shit show
yesterday, resulting in hundreds,
maybe thousands of people dying.
Why would you even want to go to school
or out, for that matter?
You all just put yourself into
the situation. Oh, you're all so stupid.
There are around 490 flights that occur
every day from Tokyo Haneda Airport.
This simply put, means that there were
too many planes for Ichiro to catch.
But we could have lessened the damage
and loss of life
if we looked at Tokyo from a population
density viewpoint.
Tokyo consists of 23 special wards
with the three central wards of Tokyo
being Teodor, Chuo and M'Naghten.
These wards consist of the most populated
areas around seven times higher
in the day than at night.
However, Chiyoda Ward is unique
and that it is the very heart
of the former Tokyo city and is one area
nearby with the least populated ward.
Aside from the fact
that this area is considered
to be the political center of the country,
this one makes Chiyoda toward
one of the best places to try and land
all those planes.
If Ichiro will failed to safely land
all those planes
within the waters of Tokyo Bay Shore,
millions of people would still die.
As can you imagine, landing
a plane in a city without a runway,
it would not be pretty.
But with this method less overall,
people would die. What?
You can't have everything you want.
People, Ichiro and Shishigami battle
it out using the latest
and greatest of their robot powers
until both of them pass out,
leaving the fighting to be done
by their self-defense mode.
Sports Ichiro self-defense mode wince
and just in time to as Ichiro
wakes up and quickly flies off
to save his daughter.
After a close call,
he miraculously rescues
her and drops her off at a safe distance
before going back to save hundreds
more revealing to the world
who the hero of the day is
and letting Japan know
that they have their own
bona fide super hero.
The next morning, Ichiro
reveals to his family who he really is.
But the sweet make up crying fest
is interrupted by news
that the Americans have failed to stop
the asteroid headed for Earth
and that this is the end of the world.
Ichiro realizes he's
the only one who can save everybody
and heroically leaves his weeping,
wailing family to go save the planet,
although he realizes that this asteroid
is too big for him to take on alone.
And that's when the craziest
thing ever happens.
Shishigami, back
from the dead with no arms,
shows up and offers to help out, claiming
that there is some good
in this world worth sparing.
He shows Ichiro a self-destruct
button hidden within their eyes
and offers to blow himself up to help
alter the course of the asteroid.
Ichiro agrees and after
for what seems like
the biggest explosion ever Shishigami
disappears, leaving Ichiro.
However, Shishigami
sacrifice wasn't enough
and he didn't change the course
of the asteroid.
Ichiro needs to blow himself up,
leaving the world and his family behind.
Ichiro decides to sacrifice himself
and blows himself up,
altering the course of the asteroid
and saving the earth in the process.